we are the cast of Wednesday and we are
going to take the BuzzFeed quiz that's
not the line
um
we are the cast of Wednesday and we're
here with BuzzFeed no I got it I got it
I'm sorry I'm just I feel the pressure
[Music]
obnoxious loud noises though
[Music]
noises you probably weren't there for
most of the noises dude but there was
hella all right I guess we weren't okay
see parties private noises yes okay me
and my homie were making private noises
together
yes exactly
what does Jenna Ortega look like now I
look like Michael Kane in a general
Ortega scramble suit
if you were a Pokemon what would your
power be and what cute sound would you
make
I don't know Squirtle Squirtle
keep going and I guess the noise would
be um
I don't want that to be on camera
forever
[Music]
I think we all know the sound Squirtle
would make and I'm not falling for your
game I don't know what a squirtle is not
doing it but it's all right thank you
my woman
that is my nickname for okay my wife
anyway I'm sorry the yes sorry I look at
you I get so I get I my heart anyway
um
we're about to single somebody out yeah
oh yeah this one guy it was a really bad
actor dude I don't know man I feel like
I I always feel like I forget my lines
more than everyone else but you guys
probably not feel that way too right no
it was Percy yeah let's just be a person
the cast of Wednesday tries not to laugh
oh
my God
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] me man
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I don't I don't really I don't
really dip things hold on a minute
okay so let's say would you dip a french
fry in in uh ketchup no you would not
I'm not a big ketchup guy okay you're
not even a guy really you know
how tall is Jenna Ortega I'm six foot
four we've got my head in the clouds
hmm beautiful
hmm
[Laughter]
[Music]
silence is deafening specific
what song is on your do not playlist I'm
not I'm not I'm not big on pop and I
feel like a couple years there was a
song out called dance monkey if anyone
ever played that in my house they're
instantly being kicked out I'm sorry
what's that one song that we would hear
in the Ubers all the time oh my God
don't say sweet dreams because that's
safe that's sacred no it's the it's the
Pink song that constantly played in the
Ubers in Romania it was the only song on
the radio that's the only song I heard
the entire time we were there I thought
we should know it we've listened to it
like a hundred times it's the one with
her kid the kid yeah I'm so sorry to
Pink and her child this is not about you
this is about the amount of times we
heard it in Ubers and Romania but see
people have come back from the dead so
is it possible that maybe Wiens isn't
dead or could come back in a possible
season too
we haven't seen her put in the ground
have we
very very true
down below
I can't tell under I can't tell is that
a calendar I'm trying to say
down under no he didn't make that movie
I don't know can we have a clue are you
sure
no just go just go just go just go to
movies in your head around 17 down 17.
the number doesn't matter the number
doesn't matter Dark Shadows because they
live forever oh I'm trying to think of
his movies right now and that does not
make sense at all is it Wednesday wow
my first heartbreak when I was 11 and I
had gotten this beta fish and I had this
beta fish for maybe two years and it
committed suicide I this tank and the
littlest tiniest baby hole at the top I
don't know how he did it and he jumped
through that hole one morning and I was
going to La that day to go to work and
my sister had known because she had
gotten up for school and I came around
the corner
I came around the corner to check on him
and feed him my sister said oh don't
worry I fed him already and pushed me
through the door I went to work I think
it was on the Jane the Virgin set and
then driving back home that night my mom
said you're gonna go inside and Kobe
stink is gonna be empty and I cried like
a big baby that was one of my first real
Subs
foreign
[Music]
such a cruel world choose something
spooky and fun to watch for your next
movie night Hocus Pocus Casper
Beetlejuice The Nightmare Before
Christmas Corpse Bride or it I think
Beetlejuice
[Applause]
I love Beetlejuice that's my girl Hunty
uh you're from Fort Smith Arkansas the
third largest city in Arkansas lungs are
the third largest organ in the human
body how long can you hold your breath
do you know what the largest organ is
skin sorry continue
[Music]
14.
team
60
21 22 is gonna make me keep counting 24
28.
29 30. okay I'm uh I'm done was that
super entertainment 38. I knew you were
counting too slow oh am I
I want nothing to do with this guy um
hidden talent is it soccer
give me something else yeah I guess you
could say well right now I just painted
my nails oh you did approximately 20
seconds yeah because I've just been job
to job and they were chipped and not
pretty but somebody like my publicist
pointed out she said oh wow that's like
a hidden talent so they look really good
it looks like a gentlemen manicure thank
you you guys got to do this iconic carry
out the prom kind of scene
how was that to film like what was that
experience like called frigid yes
fridges very frigid but very fun
bonding bonding
I know all of us chaotic that's behind
the scenes and there's like little
blankets like covered in sticky blood I
was dressed like uh kind of kind of like
Colonel Sanders okay I'll see you guys
according to Tim Burton and one of the
scenes like before we started shooting
he like had called somebody I guess and
then he like brought out a bucket of
chicken like posed for a picture with me
with this bucket of chicken and then he
was like okay okay all right action and
I was supposed to just be like
I
got Wednesday because I'm not a boss
baby whoa
because they said that not because
you're not a busted yeah I'm so sorry